noch liefert das atomkraftwerk lingen
täglich strom für rund 3,5 millionen
haushalte doch damit ist bald schluss
ende des jahres werden die letzten drei
akw in deutschland abgeschaltet damit
haben die akw gegner nach gut drei
jahrzehnten ihr ziel erreicht
doch die partei deren gründungsmythos
der ausstieg aus der atomkraft ist hat
nun ein problem energie wird immer
teurer
vornehmliche aufgabe in dieser zeit und
sie ist nicht einfach ist die senkung
und stabilisierung der energiepreise sie
ist deswegen nicht einfach weil
deutschland leben noch in einem hohen
maße abhängig ist von fossilen importen
je schneller wir also aussteigen aus den
fossilen energien so günstiger wird
unsere wirtschaft mit energie versorgt
werden können doch noch ist das vor
allem ein versprechen wind und sonne
decken heute nur die hälfte des
strombedarfs in deutschland dazu
deutschlands sonderweg in der
kernenergie
während lingen abgeschaltet wird
investieren die niederländer in
kernkraft am standort borssele
direkt an der nordsee in südholland
produziert das bislang einzige
atomkraftwerk des landes strom nun soll
dessen laufzeit verlängert werden
darüber hinaus plant die neue
niederländische regierung zwei weitere
atomkraftwerke
direkt neben dem bereits bestehenden
meiler
[Musik]
wir wollen das atomkraftwerk so lange
wie möglich laufen lassen weil die
energiemenge dies erzeugt so groß ist
dass wir sie kaum durch wind oder
solarenergie ersetzen können deshalb
werden wir auch weitere atomkraftwerke
bauen und haben dabei drei oder vier
standorte im blick
in den niederlanden machen die
erneuerbaren gerade mal zwölf prozent
des energiemixes aus das land vertraute
bisher auf seine gasreserven doch damit
ist es nun vorbei
der grund liegt tief unter den dörfern
und econ der provinz groningen hier
deuteten die holländer über jahrzehnte
eines der größten gasfelder europas aus
doch das hatte enorme folgen erdbeben
menschen gemacht heute ist fast jedes
ältere haus vom einsturz bedroht auch
diese 200 jahre alte kirche renke brahms
horst zeigt uns die schäden das ist
einer der tiefen risse die durch das
haus gehen an diesem block sieht man
dass das ganze haus abgesagt ist
die wand ist nach vorne gekippt da oben
über der tür
und auf dem boden hat sich ein richtiger
spalt geöffnet
die sorge ist sehr groß die erdbeben
werden überhaupt nicht weniger nicht
einmal als die gasförderung zurückging
sind die erdbeben weniger geworden hier
ist es immer noch sehr beängstigend
die proteste der anwohner zwangen die
regierung zum handeln bis ende dieses
jahres wollen die niederländer die
gasförderung ganz einstellen das
gaskraftwerk im niederländischen
eemshaven soll verkauft werden hollande
will weg vom gas auch um seine
klimaschutzziele zu erreichen
ganz anders in deutschland die deutschen
setzen auf gas so wie hier in lingen 15
weitere gaskraftwerke sollen in
deutschland gebaut werden gas als
brückentechnologie für mehr klimaschutz
so sieht das die regierung in holland
verwunderung
can use können sie noch verstehen was
die deutschen machen
ehrlich gesagt nicht schon gar nicht
weil deutschland ein sehr großes land
ist und unter geopolitischen
gesichtspunkt denke ich wird es doch
nicht von russland abhängig sein das
gilt natürlich auch für die niederlande
in geringerem umfang vielleicht denn wir
sind ja ein kleineres land
der holländische unternehmer leon am
alan weiss wie wichtig bezahlbare und
sichere energie ist er importiert
exotische pflanzen aus mittelamerika die
er in seinen gewächshäusern weiter groß
zieht das kostet viel energie der
pflanzen händler versucht schon lange
sich vom gas unabhängiger zu machen er
hat eine große anlage zur gewinnung von
erdwärme installiert
als gas billiger war war geothermische
energie eigentlich eine zu teure option
aber wir haben uns trotzdem für die
erdwärme entschieden weil wir in zukunft
nachhaltig produzieren und so vom gas
wegkommen wollen
wer allein auf gas setzt hat ein echtes
problem die hohen energiepreise machen
der branche zu schaffen
wenn die kollegen ihr gas nicht für
einen bestimmten preis gebunden haben
auf dem freien markt einkaufen müssen
bekommen sie nächstes jahr probleme ich
fürchte 20 prozent von ihnen geben auf
brüssel in europa ist ein streit
entbrannt wie die energie krise in den
griff zu bekommen ist die eu-kommission
schlägt einen kompromiss vor ihr
zauberwort taxonomie förderung von
investitionen in gas und atom kraftwerke
für die deutschen grünen
inakzeptabel ja co2 neutral und einem
gewissen sinne sind die atomkraftwerke
aber nachhaltig also umweltfreundlich
das sind sie ganz gewiss nicht und
deswegen ist diese taxonomie
entscheidung falsch die deutsche
regierung betont die sicherheitsrisiken
und die ungelösten probleme mit dem
atommüll
der niederländische ministerpräsident
rutte erwartet dass die deutschen trotz
dem einlenken
deutschland muss sich entscheiden ob sie
dagegen stimmen oder sich enthalten
für die niederlande gilt dass die
kernenergie sehr wohl und gerne in den
vorschlägen zur taxonomie sehen wir
zögern aber beim gas als brennstoff
im klartext nur wenn die bundesregierung
im taxonomie streit bei der atomkraft
nachgibt erfüllen die niederländer die
wünsche der deutschen nach mehr gas
ironie der geschichte ausgerechnet im
atomausstiegs land deutschland werden
brennelemente für akw in ganz westeuropa
produziert in lingen protestieren sie
dass die fabrik nicht längst geschlossen
wurde
das hatten auch die grünen immer
gefordert
nachfrage beim wirtschafts und
klimaminister
airbags ministerium antwortet
ich muss sie um verständnis bitten dass
wir keine auskünfte erteilen können weil
dies betriebs und geschäftsgeheimnisse
der beteiligten unternehmen betrifft
das überzeugt mich kein bisschen denn es
ist ja sicherlich auch von jeher immer
schon grüne überzeugung gewesen gegen
die atomkraft gegen die atomkraft zu
sein und dagegen anzukämpfen und wenn
man jetzt auf einmal sagt ja jetzt
müssen wir aber erst mal noch ein
bisschen überlegen und wir wissen noch
nicht genau und wir warten noch mal ab
ist das für uns hier völlig
unverständlich
selbst wenn das atomkraftwerk in lingen
längst abgeschaltet ist liefert die
fabrik brennelemente unter anderem auch
nach holland zum atomkraftwerk in
borssele
[Musik]